What are these speeds, and why does my
airspeed indicator have a bunch of
random colors all over it? In this
video, I'm going to explain all that
[music] because if you know how to use
the colors and markings on the airspeed
indicator, then flying an airplane gets
way easier.
Welcome to Free Pilot Training. I'm
Josh, and I know what you're thinking.
What does the airspeed indicator have to
do with aerodynamics? Why don't we just
wait and talk about that when we go to
talk about instrument stuff? As you may
remember from the last few lessons on
aerodynamics, almost everything we've
been talking about has to do with
relative wind and how it affects our
airplane. So, as a pilot, we need an
instrument that can show us how much air
is flowing over and under our control
surfaces.
This allows us to know how to control
the airplane because an airplane handles
differently depending on the airspeed
that we're flying. And if we get too
slow, things can get kind of dangerous
because we don't want to stall.
And if we go too fast, we don't want to
overload or over-G the airplane.
So, as you can see, it's super important
for us to know our airspeed, but this is
where things can get confusing because
there are actually a few different kinds
of airspeed. Keep in mind, the airspeed
indicator in your aircraft does not
actually tell you how fast the aircraft
is moving. For example, let's say I'm
flying between these two points in space
and they're exactly 60 nautical miles
apart. If it takes us 1 hour to fly this
distance, we're traveling exactly 60
nautical miles per hour or 60 knots.
But here's what you need to understand.
60 knots is our true airspeed in this
case. And your airspeed indicator
probably did not read 60 knots the whole
way.
I like to tell people that the airspeed
indicator is wrong on purpose, and I'll
explain why that is in just a minute.
Now, this is a common misconception, but
technically, your true airspeed does not
change as you gain altitude. If it takes
me 1 hour to travel this same distance
at a higher altitude, I'm still moving
at a true airspeed of 60 knots up here
as well.
Now, there is less air up at higher
altitude, so my airplane may be capable
of flying a faster true air speed
because there's less drag up here. But,
the aircraft also doesn't make as much
power up here, either. So, you may not
always be able to fly faster. And this
is important to remember because true
air speed doesn't necessarily increase
with altitude. So, true air speed does
not change with altitude, but indicated
air speed does. And I'll explain why is
in just a minute. But, before we do, let
me explain a couple of the things first.
Like I said, our speed in between these
two points in space is our true air
speed. But, now let's throw some ground
underneath these two points. If there's
no wind whatsoever and my aircraft is
traveling at 60 knots true, it's still
going to take me 1 hour to fly from this
point to this one.
But, if I have a 10-knot headwind, it's
going to take me longer to get there.
In fact, if I have a 10-knot headwind,
that means that I'm only traveling 50
knots over the ground. This is what we
call our ground speed. Keep in mind, I'm
still traveling at 60 knots true air
speed. I guess you could say that I'm
traveling through 60 nautical miles of
air in this situation. But, we're also
flying at a ground speed of 50 knots
because of this 10-knot headwind. And of
course, our air speed indicator is still
wrong.
Unless, of course, you're super lucky
and the conditions are perfect. Your
ground speed very rarely equals what you
see on the air speed indicator. And
right about now, you're probably
thinking that this air speed indicator
is just about as useless as a white
crayon. But, that's where you'd be wrong
because there are two main things that
an airplane has to produce in order to
be able to fly. And if you can't
remember what those were, I'll give you
a hint. They are two of the four forces
that act on an airplane while it's in
flight. These two things are thrust and
lift. In order order the weight of an
aircraft and the drag that keeps the
aircraft from moving forward, we must
produce thrust and lift. And here's what
you have to keep in mind. The amount of
thrust and lift that your airplane
produces depends on two main things, the
thickness of the air and the amount of
relative wind or air that goes over the
wings.
The thicker the air is, the easier it is
for your propeller to push the airplane
forward through the air.
And when the air is thicker, your
aircraft can produce more lift as well
because there's more air going over the
top and bottom of the wings. So, if the
air is thinner, we want to know about
that because we need to fly a faster
true air speed in order to produce the
same amount of lift. When the air is
thinner, our engines also have to create
more thrust because there's less air we
can use to push the aircraft forward.
This means that we really need to pay
attention to the thickness of the air.
And this is something really important
you're going to hear me talking about
throughout this entire series.
Anytime you're at a high altitude or
when it's hot or humid outside, the air
is thinner. So, you need to fly a faster
true air speed in order to keep the
airplane from falling out of the sky
because that thinner air might not be
able to produce enough lift to keep your
airplane from stalling.
Now, if only there was a tool that would
tell us our air speed in relation to the
air pressure outside. Well, that's
exactly what the air speed indicator
does. It gives you what I like to call a
pressure corrected air speed. So, you
don't have to worry about correcting
your true air speed for takeoffs,
landings, or anything else. You can just
fly the indicated air speed on this
little device without having to worry
about air pressure, temperature, or
humidity.
Keep in mind, relative wind is something
that can also affect the amount of lift
that our wings produce. And if you
didn't know better, you might think that
you need to take these into account and
add or subtract them to your speeds
anytime you're flying, but you don't
need to do that. Your air speed
indicator already takes relative wind
into account. When air enters the pitot
tube of your aircraft, it's taking what
we call ram air from the relative
movement of the aircraft. And any wind
that you fly through either reduces that
air or it increases it. A headwind will
increase this total wind and a tailwind
will reduce it. And this total wind is
what we call relative wind because it's
the total of all the air molecules
moving into the pitot tube, which just
so happens to be the same ratio of air
flowing over the wings. The airspeed
indicator then compares this relative
wind to the ambient air pressure from
the static port to give you an indicated
airspeed that you can actually use for
safe flight. What an ingenious little
device.
Could human beings really be smart
enough to create something so
spectacular?
Or perhaps ancient aliens were involved?
Um probably not because even though it's
a smart idea, the old airspeed indicator
still has minor flaws.
Remember, the airspeed indicator
compares the ambient air pressure all
around the aircraft with ram air that's
brought in through the pitot tube. And
unfortunately, anytime the angle of
attack on your aircraft isn't perfect,
your airspeed indicator doesn't read
exactly the way it should. It's usually
super close, but it's not perfect. So,
if you want to know what your indicated
airspeed should be in a perfect world,
you have to find your calibrated
airspeed and almost every airplane out
there has a chart like this in the POH
that tells you what your real pressure
airspeed should be. And this is what we
call calibrated airspeed. As you can
see, indicated airspeed and calibrated
airspeed are typically only a couple
knots off in most configurations.
And when you're out cruising around,
your airspeed indicator is typically
right on the money. But even then, the
old airspeed indicator is still much
better than trying to fly a true
airspeed and guessing what the air
pressure is outside or thinking about
what the wind is doing, even though your
airspeed indicator is technically wrong.
So, your airspeed indicator is
essentially a tool that you can use to
evaluate the aerodynamic health of your
aircraft. And if you can understand
that, it's going to help you make safer
decisions when you're out flying around.
Now, in just a minute, I'm going to
explain some of the speeds you should
know about that can help you understand
this aerodynamic health that I'm talking
about. And this is going to help you
understand how to safely operate an
aircraft. But, before I do, I'd like to
ask you for your help. If you're
enjoying this totally free training,
please consider checking out free
pilottraining.net and see if there's
some training resources that you're
interested in over there. It really
helps me to be able to make videos like
this, and it helps you to get the most
out of your training. For example, a lot
of pilots have told me that my landing
book called the triangle method has
[music] significantly improved their
landings. And I'm here to tell you that
if it saves you 1 hour of flight time,
[music] $10 for one book can save you a
couple hundred dollars on your flight
training. [music] And that's just one of
my great products. So, please take a
look over there if you have time after
this video. Thanks for giving me a
second to talk about that. Now, let's go
back to talking about how we can use the
airspeed indicator to determine the
aerodynamic health of our aircraft. And
this is really going to keep us safe
when we go fly. When we're talking about
airspeed and how it relates to
aerodynamics, a lot of times you'll hear
us use the term V speed. This V stands
for velocity, and anytime you use a V
speed, it's going to be in relation to
your indicated airspeed. Because we're
talking about the velocity of those air
molecules going over and under the
wings. I do not care about my true
airspeed when I'm talking about
aerodynamics. All I care about is the
air molecules that give me lift, thrust,
drag, power, and all that. Because of
this, when an aircraft manufacturer
designs an airplane, they also develop
specific indicated airspeeds or V speeds
that will give you the best control over
the aircraft during specific situations,
and they can also keep you from getting
yourself into trouble. For example, VY
and VX are two indicated air speeds that
you're going to want to be very familiar
with. These are the two climb speeds
that you need to know about. There are a
few other climb speeds, but these are
the ones you should know about as a
private pilot. First, we have VY. Keep
in mind, anytime you climb away from the
ground, you should always use max power.
But, if you pitch for VY when you're
climbing out, this gives you the best
rate of climb. And this simply means
that the airplane will climb to a
specific altitude in the shortest amount
of time. So, VY is the fastest you can
get high.
Oh, boy.
That came out kind of wrong, didn't it?
But, maybe that'll help you remember
this best speed. Get high with VY. Okay,
I'll just stop there. Next, we have VX.
And once again, you always want to climb
with full power, which means that we're
controlling our air speed by pitching
the nose of the airplane up or down.
Now, by pitching for VX, this gives us
the best angle of climb. And by climbing
at a steeper angle, this allows us to
clear obstacles or trees that might be
at the end of the runway. If you're like
me, this is probably confusing the heck
out of you right now. How could best
rate and the best angle be two different
air speeds?
Well, VX is almost always slower than
VY. Actually, I think VX is always
slower than VY. And this is where some
of our previous aerodynamic lessons come
back into play. Who remembers our drag
chart? Right here, we have LD max, and
VY is typically really close to LD max
because this allows us to climb with
very little drag. But, what if we
pitched up and slowed down a tiny little
bit? What would happen? Well, we'd
increase our drag, wouldn't we? So, we'd
slow down. But, this would also increase
our lift, wouldn't it? This, in turn,
allows us to climb at a steeper angle,
which can really improve our ability to
climb out over an obstacle.
I guess you can say it really gives you
that X Factor when climbing out over an
obstacle. What do you think? Better than
get high with BY, I guess.
Okay, I'll stop. Next, we have
maneuvering speed or VA. Now, I know we
just talked about this a little bit in
one of the last lessons, but let's go
over it again real quick because this is
one that you're really going to need to
remember. Maneuvering speed is the
fastest indicated airspeed you can fly
without causing structural damage to
your airplane. At airspeeds of VA and
below, you do not have to worry about
structural damage. If you abruptly
maneuver the airplane, the airplane will
stall before structural damage could
possibly occur.
Above VA, abrupt maneuvers could cause
damage, and in extreme conditions, you
could even see structural failure. In
other words, your wings will break off.
But, for those of you who are kind of
stupid like me, orange color mean be
gentle. Red, bad color.
Sorry, I can't help myself, and I know
I'm making light of all this, but this
is actually really important because if
you decide that you want to move one of
your control surfaces very suddenly, or
you run into turbulence and you're above
VA, this is where you can really start
to get yourself into trouble. So, it's
important to know if you're flying above
or below this airspeed so you can make
good decisions.
Now, before we move on, I want to take a
closer look at the airspeed indicator
because a lot of the V speeds we're
talking about are color coded on most
airspeed indicators. And this makes
things super simple for people like me
who are kind of stupid and can't
remember simple numbers. The first
airspeed marker you should know about is
the zero airspeed marker, and I know
this might seem like common sense, but
it's super important to check and make
sure this thing is at zero when you're
sitting still during the run-up. Then,
as you begin the takeoff roll, the
needle should be moving away from this
point. A lot of pilots will call out
airspeed is coming alive to indicate
that the airspeed indicator is working
properly. If it's not, this might be a
good reason to reject because maybe you
forgot to take off the pitot cover or
something.
And this is an important point because
people have died because they took off
with the pitot cover installed. Now, you
can land an airplane just fine without
an airspeed indicator, but why would you
not check it while you're still on the
ground? Next, we have the white arc, and
the white arc signifies a safe speed to
operate flaps. At the upper limit of the
white arc, we have VFE.
This V speed signifies the fastest
airspeed we can fly with the flaps fully
extended. Technically, in most
airplanes, you could start lowering the
flaps above this speed as long as they
aren't fully extended, but I tell my
students not to do this because it's not
a good habit. You're basically a test
pilot at this point if you do this, and
it's not worth it. At the lower limit of
the white arc, we have VS0 or VSO. And
this might be the handiest V speed on
your airspeed indicator. VSO is
typically used to signify the stall
speed of your airplane in the landing
configuration. And this simply means
that the flaps are fully extended and
the landing gear is out if your airplane
has retractable landing gear. Keep in
mind, this speed is typically chosen
based on the maximum weight of your
aircraft. So, your airplane won't always
stall at exactly this speed, but it's
going to be pretty stinking close to
this most of the time. And don't forget,
this stall speed is only applicable if
you have the flaps fully extended. If
your flaps aren't all the way down, this
speed will be much higher. In fact,
here's a really easy way to remember
this V speed. VSO stands for stuff out.
Anytime you're at VSO, you'll stall with
the stuff out. But what if you don't
have your flaps extended? How would you
know your stall speed in this case?
Well, that's where the green arc comes
into play. At the bottom or the lower
limit of the green arc, we have another
V speed called VS1 or VSI. This is your
aircraft stall speed with the gear and
flaps retracted. Once again, this speed
is typically made at the maximum weight
of the aircraft. So, it's not going to
be perfect, but it's usually pretty
close. This is why we tell you that an
airplane will always stall when you
exceed its critical angle of attack. We
want you to know that there's an
indicated airspeed that will be close to
this critical angle of attack. And you
can remember this airspeed by thinking
stuff in. My airplane will stall with
the gear and flaps in at the bottom of
the green arc or VS 1. With that in
mind, I do want to mention that this is
not your power-on stall speed. If you
apply power, the wings of your aircraft
will receive a little bit of extra
relative wind from the prop wash. And
this is going to reduce your angle of
attack slightly. So, don't let that
confuse you. The bottom of the green arc
is simply the power-off stall speed with
your stuff in.
At the top or upper limit of the green
arc, we have VNO. I always think of VNO
as the normal operating limit. This is
what we call our maximum structural
cruise speed. You don't want to normally
fly above this limit. More specifically,
this is the fastest speed you want to
fly in smooth air. If things start
getting rough, you definitely want to
get yourself down into the green arc to
keep yourself from damaging the
aircraft. Next, we have the yellow arc,
and this is what we refer to as the
caution range. If you fly in the yellow
arc, you should only do so in smooth
air. And even then, you should proceed
with caution. Any abrupt control
movements can seriously damage the
aircraft. At the bottom or lower limit
of the yellow arc, this is once again
VNO. Normal operations should always be
done below the yellow arc. With that in
mind, most POHs will specifically tell
you that you should only operate in the
yellow range in smooth air. Unless the
POH states otherwise, most pilots take
this to mean light turbulence and below.
If you don't know what light turbulence
is, you shouldn't operate in any
turbulence in the yellow arc. It's not
worth the risk. At the upper limit or
top of the yellow arc, we have a small
red line. And this indicates VNE.
VNE stands for never exceed, and I'd say
that's pretty self-explanatory.
If you operate above VNE, it can result
in structural damage to your aircraft or
even structural failure, even if you're
in smooth air. Remember, red is bad
color, and you should never exceed the
speed. Now, I do want to mention a
couple more V-speeds that aren't
typically marked on your airspeed
indicator. These have to do with an
aircraft that has retractable landing
gear. And as a private pilot, you could
get an endorsement to fly an aircraft
with retractable landing gear.
First, we have VLO. This is the maximum
speed you can fly and still be able to
safely raise and lower the landing gear.
I like to think of this as the landing
gear operating speed. You have to be
below VLO to safely operate the gear.
Then we have VLE. This is the max speed
you can fly after the gear has already
been extended. On many airplanes, VLO
and VLE are the same, but on some, the
structural integrity of the landing gear
is often strengthened once the gear has
been fully extended. This is one time
where you might see a published VLE to
let you know the fastest speed to fly
after the gear has been fully extended.
I like to remember this one by thinking
landing gear extended. And that is
everything you need to know about
V-speeds. We'll talk more about how the
airspeed indicator operates when we
discuss the pitot-static system in this
course. This is the system that runs the
airspeed indicator. But before we move
on to that subject, we're going to look
at a few more things that you need to
know about. Hey, I hope you're enjoying
this totally free training. If you are,
be sure to smash that like button for
me, and don't forget to check out free
pilot training.net. It really helps this
channel when you go over there and
purchase something. And it also helps
you, too. Thanks for watching. We'll see
you.
>> [groaning]